bonjour à derry ça va oui c'est un petit
peu envie d'en savoir un peu plus sur
valérie lemercier j'ai vu votre
spectacle
on peut commencer pas de problème
allégis mettez vos jambes
rendez vos chaussures mais ça me dérange
comme moi je peux pas passer mon oeil de
perdrix qui me fait mal c'est quoi la
famille l'entourage la renardière sais
quoi encore qui connaît pas l'avenir
c'est génial ça fait des centaines
d'années connaît la bande est ravi l'été
on fait des grandes tablées on aime en
guerre
en plus on retrouve tout le temps l'état
reculant nicolaides moment qu'on n'a pas
vu depuis des années comme des bêtes et
non moi je veux je veux que les gens
soient voyeur de choses qu'ils ont plein
de points devant d'habitude qui puisse
voir ses seins par des juristes c'est ce
que j'aime voir alors c'est ce que ça me
plaît ça tu t'es quand je serai grand
débat je m'occuperai de tous et
d'enfants parce que tu sais les petits
noirs on croit qu'ils sont grands partis
dans la grande vente mais si faste
justice tellement ils sont maigres
bah oui parce que comme ils ont très
faim ibiza val de l'eyre kantari font
comme ça fait un gros c'est vous qui
écrivez tout attendait là non mais vous
pouvez continuer à poser des questions
mais c'est possible de parler un peu
moins fort comment vous faites vous
n'arrivez ou juin je commence en filmant
donc devant une caméra j'improvise et
puis et puis après je regarde et puis
après j'ai crise récréer intérieurs au
départ c'est toujours je me film avant
il faut pas que je viens de manger mais
prune ou
sa redevance avoir j'y vais tous les
cinq minutes mais derrière j'ai bouché
vos yeux il pourra pas avec le théâtre
en général non violent et passionnant
mais on dira il dit
ou un déjà où je veux faire attraper par
mal à me relever mois déjà fait rien je
dirige et au cabinet ouais il faut
toujours que je mets mon client en moi
marrant